dozens of countries including the US are
trying to recover from a massive cyber
attack that locked up tens of thousands
of computers the targets included
hospitals companies and government
agencies cyber extortionists use
malicious software that's believed to
have been developed by a US government
agency Jonathan Vigliotti is in our
London bureau with the latest Jonathan
good morning good morning hackers
tricked victims into opening up corrupt
links in emails by disguising them as
invoices and security warnings this
Trojan horse technique is rather
primitive but highly effective and
yesterday's attack is believed to be the
largest of its kind the virtual attacks
at the UK's National Health Service into
emergency mode ambulances and patients
were turned away from hospitals across
the country after malicious software
crippled their computer systems making
access to patient records impossible
they said I'm really sorry but their
computer system is down and you're going
to have to go away we can't have any
appointments it would be dangerous to do
so can't access any of the files hackers
encrypted those files rendering them
unreadable to decode them they demanded
$300 in ransom the amount would double
after three days if ignored they warned
data would be destroyed the malware
program appeared to exploit a
vulnerability in Microsoft Windows first
identified by the US National Security
Agency and later leaked in a series of
stolen documents the hack wasn't just
limited to computer systems in the UK
businesses across Europe including
Spain's telephone system were targeted
Japan Turkey and the Philippines were
also infected and in the u.s. FedEx was
hit but it appears the brunt of the
attacks were felt in Russia including
the country's largest mobile phone
company cyber experts say guarding
against such malicious software is easy
but often overlooked if you keep your
security up-to-date if you make regular
backups of your important data then you
can recover from an instant of this the
problem is many organizations don't
defend themselves in advance against
ransomware attacks and don't have
backups here in the UK Prime Minister
Theresa May
there was no evidence patient data had
been compromised it could take several
days though to fix the system at this
point analysts say the hack appears to
be the work of cyber criminals and not
state-sponsored Dana Jonathan Vigliotti
in London thank you